did you perform two live audiences for
example
in like your high school talent show was
there some evidence that you actually
had the the these um uh
not just passions but also like frankly
ability
well i'll tell you this uh i i'll be the
first to tell you
like 14 you know 14 year old uh jin
you know it was one thing to mimic and
emulate the rappers that i loved
right in this case whether it's ll cool
j whether it's
crisscross whether it's whoever right
but to actually
you're right what does it mean in terms
of my own craft like
are you writing your own raps gin are
you performing at the talent show
yes so to answer your question yes so
there were several
talent several talent show experiences i
definitely started working on my own
compositions
and i will be the first to say they were
garbage
they were hot trash uh you know but
everybody starts somewhere and um but i
have fond memories of that too
of that process uh because aside from
the parents right so
you cover the asian parents side but uh
another fascinating aspect to me is
one reason why i loved hip-hop so much
because there was a camaraderie to it so
my close circle of friends right like my
let's say close three four friends that
was like our clique
that was our little squad we were all
into the same things naturally the nba
we all love playing ball and in this
case hip hop
right like we just loved hip hop and the
funny thing is these are some of my best
like bffs so to speak friends that i
still keep in touch with
to this day and i'm grateful for that
too you know we're all about to be
close to 40 right but i remember vividly
that even within this
small circle of friends these are my
brothers my comrades
they're like yo jim ain't nobody trying
to hear you rap yo nobody
these were not those friends really the
big question is like
how the heck does someone break into the
music industry
like you know as like a 19 year old kid
like you you show up in queens
like what the heck was that process like
because for for me and i remember
when you did start winning these rap
battles on bet on 106 in park yeah yeah
106 in park i think that was
uh like probably uh like a couple years
after you arrived in new york but that
that was
when you started hitting the radar of
popular culture and and
you know like uh people like me i mean i
feel like all along
i was looking for this big break so in
miami i was
already like you know as mentioned
before probably
a definitive moment was graduating high
school
so okay yes i don't have sat scores to
share
but i do have a graduation diploma a
pivotal moment was after
graduating i kind of already was full
steam ahead so this is in miami i'm
doing demo tapes
i'm trying to get into every single
battle competition that i can
i'm trying to get into every talent
showcase that i can and i'm literally
running around the streets of miami just
battling
like just freestyle battling any and
everywhere at the mall
at the movie theater at the arcade
everywhere so i think the thing is when
i made the move to new york
i was in the same mindset but just now
it's a whole new playground for me
so i'm running around times square
battling like just like
who raps who raps i'll battle anywhere
uh in the village
there used to be a record store iconic
called fat beats
at the corner of sixth and eighth where
there used to be a grace papaya
the grace papaya isn't even there
anymore but there was a record store
called fat beats
and i used to stand in front of the fat
beats record store
both freestyle battling and basically
selling mixtapes like like uh yeah like
mixed cds
and just be like i was that guy i was
that guy
i was the hey yo you listening to
hip-hop yo check this out check this out
man
i was that guy so this is kind of the
the year or so
leading into the 106 in park to get on
106th and park you probably have to try
out or something
yeah i went to uh and i'm super like i
i have a strong vivid memory and it's
something that i i hold dear to my heart
is the fact that
i went to just a traditional
conventional
open casting call along with the other
you know 300
you know hopefuls right the other 300
roughly 100 200 300
people that had the same vision as me
like yo i'm gonna get on this stage
and this is gonna be my big break so i
think that's the thing is like i had
always been looking for the big break
and in this case the the 106 in park it
was the big break
you know so for those of uh uh you
listening who don't
know what we're referring to there was a
show on bet called 106th and park that
would just have rap battles
yes and you'd have a champion the
champion would come back every week
and so jyn ended up setting the record
for
uh how long someone reigned seven weeks
well there wasn't there was one guy i
always like to
i'm i'm the guy that's always very
adamant about giving proper credit to
for me there was one guy before me that
actually
he he did the uh they call it the seven
week run right
and after seven weeks there's this
notion of like all right this guy
he you know he's already proven himself
so we're putting him in the hall of fame
so there was a guy before me his name is
poster boy
so so i always like to acknowledge him
because
he he ran so that i could fly right so
shout out to poster boy well it's so fun
so after you win
seven weeks in a row they put you in the
hall of fame i mean
that's pretty dope so so you get up
there you start winning
uh i'm gonna guess that uh of those two
to three hundred people you were
probably the
only asian american ding ding ding ding
ding ding
yo you clearly did the math
yes i um i i will attest unless unless
someone were to come out otherwise
because i clearly do not i would have
remembered
if i was there at that point you would
have noticed like the other age
i would have noticed another asian dude
there if i was
like if i i remember on that day of
auditioning
you know you show up and you look around
and it's just
a sea of rappers you know from queens
from brooklyn from manhattan the bronx
staten island just everywhere some even
from out of town actually because
everyone's just
vying for a spot on this stage to
showcase themselves
uh but yeah i think i would have
remembered if i saw another asian
you would have remembered man because
you know
[Laughter]
so you win seven weeks in a row and then
shortly thereafter you become
signed to uh rough riders it's like a
major major rap label
um so was that directly off of uh 106th
and park yeah
so it's it there's like a fairy
tale-esque
aspect to all of this because
roughriders
as it stands was one of my childhood
like dream labels to be on
right like i think as a 16 17 18 year
old
your your dream is like okay how do i
sign with dr dre
how do i sound with you know the
neptunes or how do i sound with
rockefeller rough riders like i'm from
that era right like you mentioned
i was born in the 80s grew up in the 90s
so at the peak of my
you know like hip-hop journey up to that
point
these were the end the end game was to
either
yo rockefeller rough riders who wherever
the door opens
so in terms of rough riders they
actually reached out
um before i won seven weeks so i think
maybe a little bit past the halfway mark
after i had won three or four weeks
they already reached out we were already
having uh conversations
and they were so committed and they
believed in my
i guess my journey so much that they
said hey if we can close this deal out
even before you win the seven weeks
yes yes they said after you win it
um they let they kind of spoke it into
existence they're like after you win
on the seventh week right there is when
you will announce that you've signed
with rough riders
and this is all and i'm so grateful
because this is essentially all
documented and it's captured and it
lives forever
on film right so i win the battle and
the host
free and aj they're like yeah jen so man
congratulations you know how do you feel
right now
and i'm like how do i feel well i've
signed with roughriders
and i like and there's this iconic
moment that i forgot about
and recently someone brought it back up
to me uh on clubhouse
they were like gin i'll never forget
after you won the seventh week
you announced that you signed with
roughriders and you you you went in your
sweater
and you pulled out the rough rider chain
and you like put it in your mouth
and you've been on it and and i'm like
damn i don't even remember that but
apparently to this eighth grader right
he was probably in the eighth or ninth
grade at the time
he was like yo i'll never forget that
but the beauty of this is
it would be one thing if it was like an
asian kid right because i i encounter a
lot of that like asian
let's say male male male and females
right that are in their 30s now
so at the time they might have been like
a junior high or a high school kid
and they'll tell me the the the story of
man i used to be
you know running home on friday to watch
it just to see someone that
remotely look like me so those tales i'm
always grateful and i cherish
but this particular story about the the
you pulled your chain out and you put it
in your mouth it was a it was um uh
african american guy right that was like
yo i was in the eighth grade
and for some reason jen that moment has
sit with has sat with me
for like 20 years now just when you pull
the chain out and you put it in your
mouth
and you were like yeah i'm rough riders
now and i'm just like
that's the power of you know like of of
cultural
connection you know i mean here you have
a chinese kid on
black entertainment television with a
young black kid
watching it but everyone's just like you
know just
connected and there isn't you know
necessarily like a feeling of like
yo this doesn't make sense it made sense
that it made sense to me on stage
it made sense to this eighth grader as
he's watching it so i don't know like i
cherish
that i cherish that
you